[Music]
all right everyone I'm Jim Josh Fidel
I'll be going over a strategic game so
for this one I chose actually one of my
favorite strategic games this was played
in the super tournament of alone ours in
1991 White was got a cop's key who's one
of the top u.s. grandmasters won the US
Championship many times against Anatoly
Karpov who was of course world champion
not at that time but he was in late
seventies early eighties so this was
this was quite an interesting game so
let's get to it
d4 Knight f6 new minion Knight f3 c5 III
so this is I'd say not the most
ambitious set up as white but of course
it's perfectly perfectly playable 96
this should be three Bishop takes c3
pawn takes d6 so this is actually quite
typical for when this happens basically
that's when black ops 2 give the double
pawns
the idea is now to do what with your
pawn structure what do you guys think
where do you think blacks gonna put the
pawns exactly so you put all the pawns
on the dark squares this might become a
weakness this pawn on c4 eventually but
not necessarily sometimes it's really
not a weakness that is attackable but
the main thing is which piece of whites
are you mainly hoping to lock down to
make sure it's never irrelevant force
exactly
if this bishop ever becomes active it
can be very unpleasant because you don't
have a mission to counter so you have to
make sure this Bishop basically stays
dead or at least as dead as possible so
white play d4 so of course what kind of
move is black gonna be looking to play
mm-hmm do you want to make sure that
your pawns get on the dark squares if
you allow white to put get get a neat 5
at the wrong moment it could be very
unpleasant so white plays d5 in general
I would say when you have a structure
like this you're very happy to see the
move d5 do you guys know why that might
be like what is it is d5 open the
position or does it close it closes the
position now what piece combination
likes to have a closed position and
which one likes to have an open position
what pieces like open positions the two
bishops so if white plays d5 you're
doing what to the position closing it so
that's probably bad for the bishops
right this is not always true I would
say this is one of those things that's
often over estimated it's not so much
whether the position is closed but
whether it's able to remain closed if
the position stays closed forever almost
always the bishops are quite bad in
those kind of positions the Knights
could have plenty of time to hop around
keep in mind Knights take longer to get
places the bishops do so if closed
positions are slower you have more time
for the Knights to get to where they
need to go but the key is that you don't
allow breaks and don't allow the
position to
open for the bishops but yeah d5 usually
happy to see like the kind of ideas that
would worry me here and I'm not saying
even in this position their best but
something like Bishop here not even
saying this is a good move but just the
idea of like say castles the knight
maneuvering around to e3 keeping the
tension keeping things a little bit
fluid those are the types of ideas you
want to use when you're playing with
bishops because bishops like fluid
positions they like positions where they
have pathways like if you know white
would be jumping with joy at least
strategically to see something like this
where now see how the bishops open so
almost always blacks not going to oblige
you but this enables you to play like 92
maybe maneuver it around to e3 again I
don't know if here that's necessarily
best but that's kind of the way white
often likes to play d5 is very committal
but it means that black can kind of do
what they pleased with the Knights so
white played h3 black played h6 I mean
these are just kind of normal improving
moves I don't think they're anything
special
Bishop to e3 Queen a5 so I think Queen
a5 is just making sure blacks white
stays tied down to the c3 pawn so Queen
b3 Queen c7 so there's actually a sneaky
purpose for this
this maneuver looks really weird at on
the surface right but I would say that
Karpov very rarely does anything without
a purpose and it's kind of funny because
I annotated this game a long long time
ago this was an assignment I actually
did a homework assignment I did trying
to annotate a strategic game so but I'm
looking at my homework assignment and I
can tell I didn't do a great job because
I think I actually can see a clear
purpose now to why I want the Queen on
b3 rather than do you want what move
would black like to play with one of the
Knights
exactly and now in that h5 is a playable
move exactly so it's actually quite
tactical car pubs are sneaky good but at
the time I was like ah [ __ ] I wasn't
really going like that but I couldn't
figure it out so I don't know why it's
not that obvious I think I needed to do
a better job with the homework so 92
indeed night h5 was played basically and
at this point I'm correct
white black really does not want to
allow f4 and why do you think that would
be that's part of it but f4 does what
does it open the position really it does
right and who does that favor the
Bishop's wanted open right so f4 is the
main idea so blacks saying no no no no
you're not playing f4 if black can't
play off for it's gonna be very
difficult to open the position so white
tries g3 black plays g5 at first a move
like this can look risky but this is
very standard in positions like this
black is trying to completely lock down
White's play prevent prevent f4 entirely
because this Knight is not exactly a
stable piece right it's gonna have to
move eventually so you're gonna need
some way to prevent f4 so I thought
maybe white could try h4 immediately
maybe as an idea but white decided to
Castle queenside I don't know it's kind
of a debatable decision but part of the
idea is that because this pawn always
hangs castling kingside is gonna be very
difficult not to mention that blacks
probably gonna play off 5 so I don't
think castling queenside is completely
out of hands so black plays Knight g6
trying to lock things down even more
Bishop to e2 Knight back to f6 this is
kind of a funny moment tactically black
might be able to play this move kind of
funny right looks like a nice move what
why do you think he didn't close
mainly Bishop g4 I mean this is a check
but I don't know if that check actually
leads anywhere but I was even thinking
you could drop back to f1 I don't know
if Bishop f1 is exactly the move you're
looking for but now it's kind of a
problem because this Knight is not
doesn't really have anywhere to go
eventually you're gonna be able to
threaten to take it with a move like f3
so car probs not lured into just putting
his Mattern f4 for no reason
he plays back note how he still keeps an
eye on f4 this is very important so
comps key tries to prepare it black
plays Queen e7 so the purpose of Queen
e7 is that you're able to clear space
for well I'd actually don't to give that
part away but in this position the Queen
tends to be more solid here and also if
black ever whatever tries to pull f4
you're better equipped to kind of deal
with these squares they're all better
defended so white plays Queen b1
and what do you guys think black those
bar how does black improve the position
queen b1 incidentally is so that if
white tries to play out for this pawn is
defended so it's all about like little
maneuvering the games which one this is
so G for you have to be a little bit
careful because G for what are you doing
to the position and you have to be very
careful with that especially with your
King here so after pawn takes pawn
what would your idea be okay but I think
you experience problems here what if I
even just play f3 you have to go back
right but you have to go back here cuz
you don't wanna drop this pawn right and
now this guy hangs so you have to be
very careful with moves like g4
unprovoked because if you open the
position you open your lines for your
opponent I would say the tricky thing
about playing these positions and I'd
say they really were well suited to
Karpov do you guys know what Karpov was
really known for what style he had apart
from being more on the strategic
positional side not that he couldn't
attack he was actually an excellent
attacker but what style would you guys
say he had those familiar
yep but one of the things he was known
for was prophylaxis which means
basically he was really good at stopping
his opponents idea there was actually a
cool saying about Karpov which was
that's the way you figured out what you
were supposed to be doing in your
position was by figuring out what moves
Karpov was preventing there were times
when he would prevent opponents ideas
that the opponent did not see and this
kind of position I think is really good
for him and he didn't play this game
excellently and one of the reasons for
that is because it's much more important
in a position like this to prevent
White's ideas than to carry out your own
that sounds kind of unfortunate like oh
man I want to do my own stuff but the
problem with the position like this is
black doesn't have any amazing ideas
there's no all right I do that I
accomplish this and I get a great
position or I do this it's more that if
white can't do anything to you your
position is very good because you have a
very solid structure the position is
very locked which is not good for these
bishops as we discussed and in the long
term White's King might be a little
weird these pawns are weak so in the
long term your position is very good but
in the short term you need to prevent
white from doing things to you so rather
than having the mindset of alright what
can I do you have to always be thinking
what is my opponent right
so rook chief it might experience
problems we'll have to remove like h4
because this might hang and that's the
thing after h4 you really want to be
able to play g4 to keep the position
locked so in this position one of the
important things is that I don't think
White's threatening to play off the
floor so in the game he played King d8 I
don't many of you had this move on your
radar
now this is actually you would know this
move if you played positions like this
before because it's actually a very
typical move for these positions there's
this particular look NIMS Oh line after
Bishop before Bishop to g5 immediately
and you get a similar structure to this
and in those lines you play this idea
all the time and it's actually very
simple
if you Castle kingside what's the
problem what is white gonna do to you
h4 and it's gonna be ugly right you're
not gonna want any piece of that
castling queenside is kind of tricky
because if you play Bishop d7 that's
always hangs and what's the problem with
playing a move like b6 what I did is
that invite in some positions exactly
the Ray that's what this guy this guy's
called the Ray a-four a-five and all of
a sudden you have a weakness so you'd
rather actually not put your pawn on v6
either so what this move does does it
get your king out of the center puts it
on a very solid c7 square and then you
can develop your Bishop looks weird
right but these are the kind of ideas
that in an open position you could never
do this white would blast open the
center your King would be on da your
opponent would be laughing at you you'd
be crying let me not cry but you'd be
unhappy but because the position is
locked because the center is so locked
you can afford ideas that are slower you
don't have to be in the same rush but we
have to make sure f4 doesn't work so
this was not played in the game but what
would you guys think to do after f4
how would you guys react
mm-hmm
so Queenie far as possible but let me
see so I was actually I was thinking
here as white you maybe could sack c3
yeah and then play Queen c2 and the
problem you have is you're a little bit
maybe this isn't so bad though you take
you play a knight here you put your
knight on e5 which is a really nice
square
maybe it's livable but I'd be a little
worried cuz rook g7 may be kidding rid
of this Knights you're really banking on
this Knight now if this Knights not
amazing if this Knight gets traded off
your King looks really bad right I like
your idea but I'm not so sure it works
out what I thought black might try here
instead was actually just maneuvering
the knight immediately notice how I'm
always looking what squares do I want my
pieces on and this square it looks
beautiful for a knight right so a knight
but I like that you looking at Queen e5
first because of the temple move very
important right but 97 to e5 and I
wasn't sure what black could really like
I could really do here the main feature
is that blacks whites King is just as
bad as yours so you don't have to really
worry it's not just oh my king is weak
like this King is also bad so I don't
know this didn't look all that
threatening but 97 I think might be an
important move trying to maneuver in the
95 I'm not a hundred percent but I'm
pretty sure that's that's why he didn't
play this he played a move I don't like
he played Knight f3 I thought for sure
he would play h4 her and maybe I can
play g4 but now there's h5 there's f3
white is at least chances to open up the
position which is what white wants to do
right
he played Knight f3 which I didn't care
for as much so Karpov continues with his
maneuverings h4 but now I don't really
like it because black can keep the
position close g4 with tempo night here
and black finds kind of a nice idea now
again what is the main feature of these
positions right the problem with a5 is
you're thinking about what you want to
do remember the main focus is the
opponent keep the opponent locked down
do not allow them to do anything
does rookie 8 prevent anything I
remember this hangs always you got to be
careful this yeah
so guys you forgot about this a couple
times so I'm gonna just leave my mouse
here never forget about this palm do not
hang it
it's that helpful trust me we've that's
an easy pond to hang but you got to keep
it track of all your pieces right you
can but this move I think black white
has a very nasty move now do you like
this pin I don't like it either probably
you just lose that's how be nasty this
pin is I'm gonna play f3 next open up my
rook mah got to be very careful about
what squares you allow played this one
so how does this stop f3 exactly so this
is what the thing I've noticed like when
people are playing positionally they
forget that you can use tactics for
positional means this isn't really a
tactic it's just you're attacking a
different pawn but it's basically you're
you're preventing something indirectly
rather than directly trying to combat
this move you're trying to attack
something else think about it that way
so you want to remember that you can use
tactics in your favor in this game this
was a very positional game but he used
tactics a lot and you'll find that the
really great positional players this is
what they do they they're good at
tactics they use them to help improve
their position to make their position
better so Knight h5 is kind of an
example also I want to add do you like
this Knight I don't like this Knight
it's kind of in the way eventually you
want to play off five right so this
Knight is not really a great piece
anyway so I like to move it so white
played Queen c2
so now what it's a little bit sad
so black further improves another sneaky
move I would say this 57 is kind of what
I expected but he played queenie 8 so
again the idea is it's kind of a sneaky
move if white allows the queen can
shrink the slingshot over here Bishop d7
sometimes it's an annoying move and then
if Queen d1 you even a Bishop a4 if you
need it and he also leaves squares for
his other pieces so I don't know it's
kind of a clever ish move white played
Bishop d3 so white wants to prevent f5
now black plays here white plays here so
what to do
there's nothing wrong with moving a
piece twice like this keep in mind this
position is very closed meaning it's
very slow you moving a piece back and
forth changing up your plans keep in
mind the White Queen is not really great
here apart from attacking this pawn
black doesn't mind moving the Queen
again so making sure you're not in a
rush is of real importance if you try to
rush a position like this it'll often
just mean you your position becomes bad
that's usually all it means you got to
take your time and only rush when your
opponent's threatening really serious
stuff that you got to prevent so white
played 9 c2 Queen g7 is interesting with
the idea of rooked f8 trying to think
there was a I mean he played this but
there was some other idea I liked ah but
Queen g7 has an added bonus to that in
some of these positions this pawn can
hang if you try to mess with this side
of the board too much so Queen g7
actually has some clever points so king
b2 is played
Brook outfit so very nice f5 now it's
kind of hard to prevent right sweet
please here so have five do you guys
want to play off five or no
that's more like it where are we in a
rush we're taking our time so he doesn't
want to allow a night to be five at all
so he's like no no no sorry next time
King day one so time for that [ __ ] why
not
what is White's idea if you could give
like two moves in a row what would they
be
remember we're mostly even though we're
playing black we're mostly thinking of
whites moves right because we're
thinking of what to prevent what is why
I want to do here if you play queen bee
to rugby one that's gonna be pretty ugly
right queen coming in to b6 so you have
to make sure whatever your move choice
is that you do not allow that so if you
play out five you have to make sure that
you can stop rook be one Queen B to in
time and if you can't what is more
important getting in f5 or preventing
White's idea pretty much the answer to
that question every single time is
preventing what they do so
what's his idea
how do you penetrate v6 now dance is
very simple you don't write v6 is too
well-guarded and this pawn is actually
hard to attack because this stupid
Knights in the way otherwise this might
be a weakness but because this Knights
here it's actually very difficult to
attack this pawn kind of funny huh
so white plays rook b3 white still wants
to gang up on that point so what is
black do he finds another way and this
is the sneaky thing he's not threatening
it yet so he plays queen g6 with what
idea
very simple what's the break you want to
play for
so queen g6 prepares at five keep in
mind if you had played rook p7 rook be
one with the idea of this this pawns
always hanging right so that's not an
ideal solution what he does is he puts
the Nancy eight so you guys might be
asking which is not a bad question like
why do you want to put a night on c8
like isn't that a terrible piece but
what do you think the answer is what
would be the counter-argument to the
knight on CA
everything's defended that's your main
goal right and it's a slow position this
is not a position we're putting one
piece on a bad square it's gonna be hard
to have all your pieces on good squares
it's just one of those positions so also
notice if these guys can't take here
they're not actually that great right if
they're not careful even Bishop a4
threatening to win in exchange might be
a move I don't even know if you want to
take that exchange and this is the other
thing when you have a completely locked
position
sometimes rooks are not as valuable as
minor pieces because there are no open
lines right no this is not always true
I'm not saying just give away your rooks
willy-nilly every time you have a closed
position but sometimes giving up an
exchange even in open positions as we
know an exchange sack can be a powerful
tool but I'd say in closed positions
rooks tend to mean a little bit less so
Bishop a4 may not even be a good idea
but it in any case calm ski didn't
really want to allow so he played here
so what now
he likes to prepare his moves very well
but keep in mind is white ever gonna
prevent f5 is that five ever not
happening there's no way to stop it
right so why should he play it too fast
it doesn't win the game right it's just
a breakthrough so he does this and what
this does for him is now when he plays
out five he has the option after Bishop
takes to maybe take with the knight
maybe that's a good option right so if
you can learn anything from this kind of
a position it's really just do not be in
a rush almost always doing things the
slow way it can be better again the
exception is if your opponent can
actually count or something or threaten
you really badly so cops Keys like
alright come on man
play it make a weakness so Karpov was
like alright I'll give you one weakness
this is the one concession he makes all
game I have 85 so cops key does a little
dance he's like yes finally I have a
weakness to work with he goes back
sometimes that's all of what positional
maneuvering is you're just trying to
provoke one weakness but look how many
moves he had to play to provoke this
weakness and notice he completely
abandoned this side of the board right
so now hello finally got an f5 huh so it
takes takes convenient that you can take
with the knight though right she does
get you back to d2
rook taffy looks like blacks making
steady progress right 9300 the weakness
is coming back to haunt you
so how does he deal with this
he plays this 197 looks a little funny
because now this guy's week right so if
I play Queen B - you have to go back
alright but rook b7 and the thing is you
created a weakness but there are times
when one weakness is just not enough
this is a weak square but what is the
knight on b5 do exactly he played back
because if you plays check the king
nicely slides here convenient move right
what's the problem
sometimes Knights people overestimate at
least in my finding nights on outpost
they look really pretty but you always
have to ask yourself what is that night
doing in attacking it's attacking this
pawn which is vented like 20 times
that's good what else is it doing
nothing right so it's important not to
be terrified of knights and outposts all
the time there are times when in either
an outpost hits all the important
squares attacks half your pawns then
okay worried about it right but there
are times when one night on an outpost
can deal with it
so white plays back carpet plays rook f6
he might want to move his queen one day
and he needs this guy defended
Queen to d1 king da what could be his
idea
that's part of it but his idea is
actually much more longer-term very nice
I know you were half joking but I can
tell you we're also half serious and
that's what counts
no this is the thing the King here it's
hard to make progress with the King here
because if you try to move your pieces
out your Kings kind of open right the
Queen might come into here that just
looks annoying but say your Kings over
here your rook comes here all you have
is one passive piece and that NC eight
that's a small price to pay to restrict
this rook this rook all these pieces
right think about it it's actually
rather than having a passive knight
think about it this way it's a path it's
it's one pass of night against two paths
of rooks I'll take that trade any day so
he wanders over wander wander do you
want to wander again
why does he play this move
what would happen if you just kept going
woopsy so make sure remember his mind is
always on Bloods play more than his 97
gb3 look up three Brooke f6 you might
ask what the heck is he doing the answer
of course is he's not in a hurry he's
just probing he's seeing what White's
doing so he puts his queen in the center
Queens like to be in the center as we
know Brooke c7 tonight here so what is
he accomplished apart from making white
play the very depressing Bishop c1 where
is he headed now yes he can
headed to the Kings side and again once
his kings over here he can be a little
bit riskier because he's not getting
made it over here feel that's why I
crashed through so eventually he can try
to do something slides over night g7 he
doesn't want to get his Queen trapped by
some miracle but I'd imagine also if you
play King g7 what do you allow let's say
he were to do this yeah maybe this isn't
a big deal but why bother right remember
I always ask is it necessary to allow
this move probably not
so you goes back this Knight wasn't
doing a whole lot anyway Laidback t1
King G it
Rock up seven he's slowly accomplishing
his ideas but slowly is okay what is
white done right Quincy 600 so how do
you deal with Quincy six
yeah no big deal it's all covered this
guy hangs to by the way so he plays
Queen back tonight back to have five
notice there's a lot of back and forth
this is pretty normal in closed
positions a lot of the times you have to
go backwards go forwards again and it's
all about making small gains but notice
how White's position now remember how
this pawn was not even remotely close to
weakness before it's getting there right
that's an annoying pawn tap to defend
this bishop we were restricting it now
it's looking like a downright bad piece
so slowly we're making progress notice
how the King here looks a lot nicer than
the King here the King here would not
feel so great about itself right King
here perfectly comfortable so Bishop
goes back ripped off selling Knight to
d3 King to g7 where is he going now
what's his idea of this move
what piece mighty want to move now like
if lack of improved if black could move
one of the pieces which piece do you
think is in the way right but what's the
problem if he moves it
you forgot the friendly cursor I forgot
to leave it there this pawn hangs so
he's just defending his pawn now he can
move his knight again now he could
calculate liens where you allows Bishop
takes h6 and he goes for some sacrifice
do you think he did that why not yeah he
is a patient man way too long no I'm
actually not sure but back then the time
controls were longer it was like I think
it was I don't I don't think this was a
period where they did they used to do
sealed moves and adjournments do you
guys know what those are so basically
when you reach time control you would
actually seal right down a move seal it
and then and then the next day you would
play that move and play it out the next
morning before the next round now of
course they don't do that they have
sudden-death but even this but this time
it was a while ago so I'd say they maybe
didn't have adjournment but they had you
know multiple time controls so it's
probably 40 moves for two hours 20 moves
from one hour 20 moves for one hour so
this could have last this could have
been like eight hours of torture for a
cops key I guarantee you Karpov was
enjoying every minute of it
comps key was not and the thing is cops
key is an excellent positional player
it's one of the things he's known for
but in this game he was on the wrong
side of the action so night back t1 rook
to f6
so I mean even here you have to ask why
isn't you just going back and I'm not
sure I can even tell you on this one
let's see if we can find it sometimes
you know you ask yourself to put
yourself in their shoes and you're like
maybe he's just not in a rush Bishop III
is coming anyway and then you can't
break through so I don't know probably
he was just dilly dallying he's like
yeah
I'll take my time and sure enough
actually white kind of made this chose a
poor decision here
Queen b5 was probably best kind of
keeping the game as is and I still think
it's very bad but black has to find a
way to break through but this was
actually a really cool moment because it
shows the effectiveness of playing this
way one of the things that Karpov would
do to opponents and he did it here even
do it a very calm ski by the way is an
amazing defender extremely good defender
but what happens is it's not just the
position that makes people make mistakes
what else do you think contributes mm
hmm you get tired you get low on time
now calm ski as well as anyone was good
at standing up to all these pressures
but no one can withstand a pressure
indefinitely if you have a bad position
and you're just suffering the longer
your opponent makes you play this the
more likely you are to make a mistake so
sometimes you don't want to rush it not
because you're positioned not because
you don't have a good idea but because
your ideas aren't going anywhere and the
longer you make it last sometimes the
more likely it is your opponent will
just hand you the game without you
having to create it take any risk
without you having to do anything too
special it happens a lot and I'd say the
lower rated you go the less experienced
you go the more prone that is safer for
someone even of my level right if I'm
playing someone rated 300 points below
me it's very likely I'm gonna do this
and they're more likely to crack right
if I'm playing another GM I still might
do this but they at least have some
chances but I'd say that very few people
can withstand it indefinitely so if you
keep putting them under pressure you
keep making them find good moves
eventually they'll probably find a bad
move and in this case cops keep laid
this which is not a good move because
and it goes back and now there's a
problem what is the problem on f2 and on
seafloor and two pawns are hard to
defend at once so he played a knight d3
decided to have a snack and this is the
thing maybe cops ki saw this and just
had enough he was like you know what I'm
gonna do this and change the position
but unfortunately for him it doesn't
change it enough in his favor he plays
an interesting idea he takes on e5 in
place here so it looks like he's
changing the position right he's making
the game a little more open the bishop
looks a little nicer you know maybe
things are becoming complicated so how
you guys are from Karpos point of view
how do you restrict white's play how do
you keep white at bay what are you doing
doesn't have to be fancy just keep
everything defended if you allow white
to take this pawn it might be annoying
because then you have weaknesses right
if you allow white to take this pawn or
get the pieces in it could be banned so
just keep white at bay do not allow
white to penetrate your position and of
course you have to deal with the very
basic threat pawn takes knight right
it's a big threat so your move should
address this in some way
but rook up seven queen up seven is
possible I'm sure pawn takes knight
Knight takes pawn Abba despawning yeah
so the Queen you have to make sure you
keep an eye on all your weaknesses
that's the problem with having a pawn
like this sometimes it can become
weakness but rook up seven you don't
really need to guard the first rank so
he does this Queen goes back Luke goes
to e6
so again he's just trying to make keep
his position solid puts the pawn on e4
so yes the position has changed but
white also has lost upon and I'd say
it's a significant pun because now this
is still a weakness this is still a
weakness the key is just to keep this
king safe rook d2 so white wants to get
counter play does white black take this
pawn bishop B - yeah the funny thing is
sometimes taking a Pollak this is bad
anyway just because it activates the
bishop
sometimes pawns like this the bishop
actually hates because it blocks all
their play so instead he plays ninety
six where do you think he's headed and
then
yeah this is a very tasty square it's
gonna be very unfortunate when he lands
there well
so of course calm ski doesn't want to
allow that so what now
what's the idea
tacking upon although you can't actually
take it just yet so what other ideas
does this have
where else can this rook go
potentially you know rook d3 that can be
an annoying cutoff move
if a piece blocks here then then I can
land here so white gave a check black
went back what went here but now of
course so this is the other funny part
you get to this position and the key now
is the King actually changes its course
again place Keeney 895 so what now
this is calm skis trick do you want to
take that rook Queen d7 check would be
unfortunate imagine working all the way
to this position and missing Queen d7
check it would be quite a shame but
luckily that night on d3 is probably
worth the rook anyway keep it simple
don't allow any play what's hanging on
b6 right no big deal
I'll cover so calm ski goes back rook d6
keep the default keep it to the nine can
move Queen c2 a4 I love these moves such
a it's such a carpet just in case you
want to go to b3 no a3 is not a movie
wanted to play I can guarantee you but
he saw a night before was often in the
air not immediately because this is
checked but night before sometimes
available a3 probably is not such a big
deal but he's just running out of moves
so how to continue now you have like
totally paralyzed you eventually want to
bring some pieces in there's one piece
that's kind of annoying you though
bishops not so great you'd like to be
able to maybe even move the knight and
move a rook or do something but what's
what's gonna hang and we all know
carpals never in a rush keep in mind he
built his position to here it's not
going anywhere so how does he make
progress now because I think this is
again what separates him like so many
people would have like their mouths
would be watering here they want to
crush white really fast but he is not in
any rush whatsoever
he knows this advantage isn't going
anywhere
but there's one piece that's annoying
him this stupid rook so what to do
Queen d5 possible but I like my Queen
here I don't know about you keep in mind
this is check as well leave your queen
on this is the other thing when you're
looking for pieces to improve don't
start with ones that are already
excellent this Queen on c4 is a
beautiful piece this knight on day three
beautiful piece do not adjust them start
with pieces that aren't as good this
King was a little weird here anyway this
was check this was check why would you
deal with that right and now he's just
gonna kick this rook see you later and
now he can play what obviously you got
to see this move you don't want to drop
this pawn but his idea here was to do
what
yeah now all of a sudden White has more
things to worry about before at some
point could be a really nasty move so
you see how he's just slowly improving
even here he's not in any rush
whatsoever and it just it makes it
impossible to play like what can why do
you guys know yourself right if you have
something clearer you can do some clear
improvement to your position you just
play the move if you don't have any
clear improvements if you just have to
sit there it's much harder to do nothing
than to do something and in this
position I think though it's not a
question of calm skins resistance it's
just an impossible position so he plays
rook g7 going after the pawn so what now
he probably didn't want to retreat and
the main reason maybe this is a little
weaker now maybe this I mean you also
have to worry about bitching about for
then he calculated here and that's the
thing eventually you come to a point
where okay you should calculate some
lines right it's it's it's very rare the
whole game you can just go without
calculating but he did have an idea he
played b4 trying to push through and I'm
sure this is a movie spent time on so
first of all what is this idea on Queens
I say for
well yeah cuz otherwise I mean you're
threatening me do you think Karpov just
missed it
probably not he was a pretty strong guy
well it's his idea
well Queen c3 checks pretty obvious
question is how do you deliver the final
blow here that's Clara maybe this works
it's not what I saw
maybe rook takes b3 I don't know what I
found was it was this move I think it's
more clear-cut you have to take it right
I see one and now you have to give away
all your pieces pretty straightforward
right so that's the thing like even I
don't care how positional the game is
and you saw the whole game he avoided
any complications he kept counter play
to a minimum almost always especially if
you're playing a strong player but even
if you're playing someone who's weaker
than yourself who is you feel like it's
collapsing almost always there'll be one
tactical moment at least a moment where
you have to find a tactic and you have
to finish the game in a tactical way if
you don't play before here it's a little
inconvenient right defending this pawns
a little annoying you'd have to move
back maybe allow this but your pieces
are so good you're ready to play b4 and
you could and I can guarantee you he saw
bay 4 away in advance it wasn't just
here he saw before but it's important
that you don't forget about tactics even
if you're playing slowly even if you're
taking your time if you see that
tactical knockout you go for it so calm
Sookie played this move instead and now
of course the super ugly move I
shouldn't say ugly for black but
basically when a pawn gets here you guys
can just safely resign that's usually
the rules it's just bad
so Queen e2 95
using a few tactics right you can't take
this Queen Queen e1 and then the final
tactical blue finish them off
very nice so what's the idea of Queen
takes d6 pretty pretty nice so cops keep
laid check check the bunch but after
Queen c1 I think he just resigned
himself like I think he played Queen c1
and resigned because he saw Queen a2 and
it was probably too depressing anyway
you don't often see a player of this
strength lose like this like without
creating any counter play all game but
it really just speaks to I mean how good
I mean cuz Chomsky is good at closed
positions this speaks to really how good
comp Karpov is at him but also you can
learn a lot from games like this if
anything like learn how he took his time
he was never in a rush he only had to
calculate some tactics at the very end
which of course he usually does very
precisely that's what he's known for but
so you have to calculate tactics at the
end but the main emphasis on all these
positions was preventing opponents play
before you even think about your own it
was only when everything was prevented
did he do stuff only when nothing was
happening on the on the queenside did he
play f5 only when he had everything
under control did he play b5 before and
not every position should you should you
think like that but in in certain types
of positions if you can kind of adapt
that kind of thinking it can be can be
very nice anyway I hope you enjoyed the
game
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]